[Music]
overland belts and maritime roads
that's the simple way of describing a
sweeping global infrastructure campaign
that's seen billions of dollars spent
and hundreds of billions pledged
to invest in transport pipelines power
grids and ports
in this bloomberg special feature we
examine
criticism that china's belton road
initiative is recalibrating political
and economic alliances and beijing's
view
that it's just a means of spurring
global development
and trade the ancient port of paris is
in a hurry to be the number one port in
the mediterranean
and in europe propelling it on its
journey its pivotal role
in china's belton road initiative from
greece to germany
brussels to london will explore the
european connections
in china's grand plan i'm tom mckenzie
this is belton road china's trade super
[Music]
highway
[Music]
costco is one of the world's biggest
shippers and port operators
and that status has put it at the
forefront of the belton road initiative
china has called pereas a dragon's head
a strategic transit hub linking maritime
and overland routes state-owned costco
took over management of pier 2
in 2009 under a 35-year concession
pouring millions of euros into upgrading
infrastructure
and building a third pair in 2016
greece mired in its debt crisis sold a
controlling stake in the port authority
to costco for 370 million euros
and a promise to invest at least 350
million more
costco cemented perez's place in
beijing's new world order
the port has been a success bloomberg
intelligence says costco was in the
right place
at the right time paris handled more
than four million
20-foot containers or equivalent last
year
making it the third busiest in the
mediterranean and number seven in europe
according to port economics that's
growth of almost
200 percent compared with a decade
earlier
the port's managing director says
getting to this point
hasn't been plain sailing this is a full
competitive
business everybody is to his best
in order to win the support from the
different
carrier we can benefit from the one bear
world
initiative but another financial support
for sure
what we get is because the one bear
worldwide initiative will create more
trade opportunities
and this trade opportunity as a carrier
and as a terminal
we will benefit from that chinese
investment has supercharged pereira's
port but china's clout
has also raised concerns that local
businesses
could be squeezed out almost all the
companies in greece are small medium
enterprises
they listen to the fear
they're afraid that these huge companies
will take their business from their
hands business groups say initial
antagonism
has largely turned to acceptance and the
hunt for opportunity
there are a lot of people that they are
not satisfied because
they thought we could also exploit the
sport by ourselves
of course there are some people that
blame chinese that they took advantage
of the greek crisis but on the other
hand we very
well know that the rules of business is
that
when you find an investment in good
price you go for it
it's a catalyst it's an opportunity for
all of us to
start negotiating how we invest
paired with support the supply chain and
logistics
are hinderland and hitherland is where
we can invest
where we can take advantage where we can
use
tools like creating clusters
like creating growth of volumes
in order to produce wealth but the
belton road fueled push of chinese firms
across europe
has also stoked fears about china's
so-called soft power reach
and geopolitical ambitions chinese
state-owned firms now control
around 10 of europe's container terminal
capacity according to the international
transport forum
the european commission says it welcomes
the belton road initiative
but with caveats there are two
major issues which we want to make sure
that that happens all those projects
financed by china
and the others should be economically
and
environmentally sustainable and the
second especially course for
tender should be competitive and open
for everybody
we want to be part of this project
but all the concrete investments
must be reasonable and there are other
concerns beyond simply
how investments are implemented
the european union in particular is very
concerned about
china trying to divide
and conquer europe through the belton
road there are countries in
central south eastern
europe that are leaning forward because
they haven't recovered from the global
financial crisis as other countries have
and they really want to take advantage
of these
chinese offers for assistance and
infrastructure development
and so it's those countries many of
those countries that we see
are susceptible to receiving the
benefits of the belton road
and then turning around and
basically taking steps and actions that
support china
in other venues and in political fora
and that's where i think
european leaders are growing concern in
areas uh
where you need unanimity voting inside
the eu
and which are sensitive the chinese just
need to own so to speak one government
out of 28 to block uh common resolutions
on an in a number of areas what do you
say to those
people who are concerned that aligning
yourself so closely
with chinese state-owned companies like
costco
creates a dependency for a country like
greece for greece
in greece as greek we need investments
we need foreign investments if these
investments they have come from china
they are mostly welcome for me if they
could come from germany it would be also
very welcome
or united states
[Music]
coming up we go to germany where the ceo
of siemens tells us
why he thinks ignoring the belton road
is more of a risk
than getting on board and if you have an
initiative
good or bad right or wrong well
perceived or not which covers 70
of the global population you better take
that seriously
[Music]
while peres is china's main maritime
link into europe deutschberg
port here in germany the world's largest
inland port
is central to china's overland ambitions
every week
trains loaded with chinese goods arrive
here and they lock into a logistical web
that transports toys clothes and
electronics to consumers
across the continent
[Music]
doosberg's network of rail and waterways
made the city
an inland port a nexus for industry
its history is firmly planted in coal
and steel
with those sectors on the decline the
ceo of logistics hub
operator port is hitching his wagon to
the belton road initiative
it began with a rail link from
hewlett-packard's manufacturing centre
in china's south-western city of
chongqing it all started at least
six seven years ago the first train was
a dedicated train
from hewlett-packard into disburg
and then we saw the chance uh
with respect to this turntable and hub
positioning
acting from duisburg to china and vice
versa
as the distribution hub for for europe
since then the value of goods going
between
china and europe by rail has surged as
has the number of freight services
according to the center for strategic
and international studies
with the belton road being a major
driver
every week about 30 trains from china
arrive here
in deutsche port the chinese want to
increase that number to about 50 by 2020
they also want to decrease the amount of
time it takes it currently takes about
12 days
to get from china to germany they want
to cut that down to 10
or fewer a fast route into europe has
become more important
with the rise of industrial production
in china's southwestern regions
cities like chongqing and chengdu are
far from shipping routes on the coast
at the same time deusport seeks out
projects with cities and companies
linked to the belton road initiative to
strengthen its business
with hopes there will be knock-on
effects for its home city
we have built partnerships strategic
partnerships for instance with china
immersion which is one of the biggest
group
we are very close to a strategic
partnership with costco with the costco
group
they have all very concrete intentions
and you can imagine that part of the
strategic partnership is also an
involvement here in dispute
you've developed this relationship with
your chinese counterparts and that opens
up other opportunities for you right
across europe our clients are are global
so and
and we have to check where will be the
new trading routes or how can we
optimize
the transportation chains that is the
reason for instance why we are investing
with
with the largest logistic group in
turkey the akas group
a 50 kilometer outside of istanbul and
to build a rail port
or why we are interested in in looking
for a report in investment in trieste
because
i think trieste will become a very
important port in the maritime one belt
one road
link and then serving for for the
southern part of europe
the german chambers of commerce and
industry tells bloomberg
many members see indirect advantages
from improved logistics powered by
belton road initiative projects
but only about 30 percent see
opportunities to profit
directly at this point there's also a
level of caution
some of our major players they are
already involved
but there's only a few and then i have
to
mention also the the the risk or the
complaints about
uh the bidding process and uh it is
not yet uh evolved that
we can say it is transparent it is
inclusive
it's non-discriminatory and it is
respecting standards
what should be a good standards when it
comes to public procurement
tenders well that's interesting because
in china of course the chinese will
stress that this is
initiative that is open to all that it
is transparent but the reality on the
ground is
different to that we don't have an
overview
where is the next project and where
can competitors participate
if there is the wish that also german
companies that other european companies
can participate then we need more
transparency
and we have to sit on on at one table in
order to discuss
siemens is one of the major german
players that have embraced the
initiative
the conglomerate generated revenue of
more than 7 billion euros in china in
2017
about 9 of the total and it's looking to
deepen
the relationship like do sport the
conglomerate is hammering out new paths
for future growth after difficult times
the global shift to renewable energy
sources means siemens power plant
equipment unit
once a flagship has suffered a
protracted slowdown
so we have a structural challenge to
master
and that means you master it by
innovation but you also master it by
finding new ways of doing business
such as the belden road initiative where
obviously
almost 90 countries are being part of
and most of them don't have a
sustainable reliable and affordable
energy
so there is opportunities there those
with concerns about the initiative
say that some of the chinese companies
that you're potentially partnering with
they don't have the same levels of
corporate governance in terms of
standards that you do there are concerns
around transparency the susceptibility
of some of these
chinese firms to things like corruption
do you expose yourself to risks
and is it a price worth paying
essentially well we obviously wouldn't
pay
such a price at all because it's just a
no-go
i mean if that's true for
any economy in any country
now in this case if china wants to play
an international role
as the aspiration has been announced
they need to adhere to international
standards
and should be should there be any
deficits
due to the lack of experience how to
handle it they've got the perfect
partner with siemens because we've
learned it the hard way
but we know it now do you see china as a
competitor or a partner for the european
economy
both i think this is in today's world
there is not this
thing either your competitor or partner
or somebody else you can be
either by depending on what value you
can create to the specific project
china has always been a long-term
thinker
and i believe if the western world
doesn't get it act together on how it
designs free trade and how it interacts
also in solving problems
maybe china just says well i've got 90
countries
with 70 percent of the world's
population
maybe i just declared that brighter be
the new wto
so you need to be very mindful about
what we deal with here
because most of the economic and
political power shifts go with the
amount of people
in a country and if you have an
initiative
good or bad right or wrong well
perceived or not
which which covers seventy percent of
the global population you better take
that seriously
if any european company can make a
success of profiting
from china's belt and road initiative it
is siemens
infrastructure is in the company's dna
and its ties to china
run deep but that success will be
dependent
on european leaders and their ability to
persuade
china to make the initiative compatible
with western
business norms that's coming up
for many economies and businesses across
europe the belton road initiative
can offer new directions for growth it
also opens the way for chinese companies
however as we discover in this bloomberg
special feature
there's increasing pushback in the
corridors of power in germany france
and across the european union the greek
debt crisis provided an opening for
china to bolster
its maritime links into europe via the
perez port
winning over europe's lawmakers though
is proving
more of a challenge
when the belton road initiative was
first announced in 2013
we saw very strong support from europe
i think there was huge amount of
interest in how could european countries
benefit
we saw however in 2017 much of that
enthusiasm begin
to wane you the used doctrine constantly
currently is that it has a constant
offer to china to come and join
and a constant wish to come and join and
that's even clearer at the level of some
member states
but on shall we say our terms
at least on transparent terms which is a
condition that
most chinese projects accept those
financed by aib
do not fulfill at prison
the european commission has been working
on tightening investment screening
and rolling out a coordinated approach
across the block
currently fewer than half of eu member
states have rules to allow review of
foreign direct investments
what is our priority at the moment is to
make sure that all those potential
projects have a level playing field that
financing comes from the normal
competition
like what is the case here in europe
there's obviously an appetite in
the european union now for greater
oversight of chinese investments
to what extent is that going to impact
the belton road initiative there is a
rising
understanding amongst our member states
that as
as much as we want to be open
destination for foreign direct
investments
as we are we are probably the most open
market in the world
we must know who is investing and for
what purposes
there are also moves to reduce unanimity
voting to diminish members veto powers
particularly on political and human
rights issues
we have seen efforts where china has
gained
strategic influence in countries through
uh the benefits of the belton road to
those countries building infrastructure
and helping out with development
assistance and then using that influence
to as an advantage for china in terms of
its international efforts or in a way
that helps china politically
for example both greece and hungary
large recipients of belton road
efforts by china stepped forward to
block
a statement in the eu that would
criticize china and the south china sea
the eu is also sharply aware of china's
increasing investments
in the nearby western balkans and
eastern partnership countries
it's reaching out with a trans-european
network for transport
done quote the european way meanwhile
infrastructure builders like china
communications construction
company and their subsidiaries are
forging ahead
with deals in those regions in a rare
interview with the western media
organization
cccc chairman leo chitao told bloomberg
he sees potential in europe
despite tighter scrutiny of chinese
investments
we have principles when choosing
investments the project must meet the
highest standards of environmental
protection
and bring benefit to the country's
economic and societal development
and people's livelihoods we've gone
through experiences when governments
change
they put our projects on hold and review
them again as long as they're good for
the country
and they're a win-win everyone will go
ahead some media have different views
but i think it's because
of a lack of understanding the european
union
still hasn't officially signed off on
the belton road
initiative they point to concerns around
the transparency of the bidding process
around environmental
issues are those concerns justified do
you think
we need to promote mutual understanding
and in this respect we also need to work
with companies in western countries
including those in europe if we can
strengthen our cooperation
i think transparency will increase so
we're working with europe on many
projects
i'm curious how do you respond to
allegations of
corruption and fraud that have been
leveled at your company
and some of its projects involved and
linked to
the belt and road initiative we don't
allow and do not have
any corrupt behaviors related to any
official
because we know that this kind of
corruption is not going to help with the
company's sustainable development
and as a listed company we're subject to
market supervision
if there's corrupt behavior the company
is finished
on this we are very clear
because critics of the belton road
initiative still point to
what they would say is a lack of
transparency around some of the projects
what they would say
is uh lack of hiring of local labor
versus chinese labor and then ultimately
many of these projects leave the
countries
heavily indebted to to china that would
be the criticism there is some truth
in that criticism is there not on the
whole i think the situation will become
more transparent as the belton road
initiative progresses
on the issue of pushing up debt some
countries do have relatively higher
borrowing
i don't think that's scary as long as
the country's economy is growing enough
to digest it
it's important to see whether the debt
funded projects are good for the
country's economic development
of course i think it's necessary for
developed nations to offer financial aid
to countries that lack development
capability as for labour
currently my overseas ratio is at least
one to ten
in my company there's one chinese person
employed for every 10 foreigners
the labor cost of a chinese employee is
much higher than that for a local
many developing countries are still
catching up and their cost of labor is
lower than
ours therefore from the company's
perspective
we want to localize as much as possible
hire local people
and use fewer chinese i can't say there
are no problems
or that we're perfect but the reality is
it's not as people say either
i think it's because of a lack of
understanding
for both europe and china the potential
for business opportunities
around the belton road initiative are
significant yet too often
a lack of transparency is stoking
concerns
fueled by the fact that many of the big
chinese companies involved
are state-owned china needs to
realize that the way that it sees its
belt and road initiative
is not necessarily the way other
countries see
their belton road initiative this is
very important for china
it is now president xi jinping's
flagship international
program it's embedded in the chinese
constitution
the international community i think
should look at the belt and road
initiative and figure out
where countries can partner with china
where they will maintain and meet the
international standards that we hold so
dearly
and where they're not we ought to be
stepping forward to put
credible alternative proposals forward
that maintain those high international
standards
that have transparency sustainability of
projects
and have the labor and environmental
standards that we care so deeply about
[Music]
europe's leaders are trying to remain
open-minded about the potential
opportunities around china's belt and
road initiative
but it's clear that locking in full eu
support
will require beijing to translate
rhetoric into reality
particularly around issues of
transparency sustainability
and inclusiveness some european firms
are
hungrily eyeing dividends but those are
likely
still years away i'm tom mckenzie
thanks for watching
[Music]